uh we are following all of these
developments of course and this latest
uh the siren activity we're hearing in
kiev right now the capital of ukraine
want to get a read on that from a
ukraine parliament member uh
taking up arms to help defend ukraine
kind enough to join us
right now uh
and and she is there i thought you were
going to be on the phone so i'm very
happy to see you kyra ruddick uh let me
ask you about how you feel about this
when you hear news uh what's going on
in the capital and and the sirens going
off i mean your knee-jerk reaction is
obviously the russians are there um
they're probably very frustrated they
might be getting very desperate how do
you feel about all that
i feel angry
so i feel angry for the last five days
uh since the war started because the
normal lives that we used to hell like
and
fight for and fight for in ukrainian
parliament now it's all gone
for us for our children for our families
and we have to stand up and fight
russian army who just wants to attack us
because putin decided that we
don't deserve to live and he was pretty
adamant about that he said that there is
no ukrainian nation there is no ukraine
all in all
and right now we want to prove him wrong
we decided that we will stay
and i decided to bear arms and protect
my family my house my city and my
country to make sure that no russian
aggressor is coming and deciding what's
best for us
that no aggressor is coming and taking
over our cities and you see for the last
five days putin didn't have like a good
victory that he could be proud of none
of the large ukrainian cities uh is
taken there is not even a picture that
he controlled to russian citizens to
prove like why did he start this war
because it's every single step of the
way ukrainian resistance is kicking his
ass and doing it very very
well know kyra i'm wondering i'd like to
see you with your political office and
and the fact that you and so many uh
ukrainians are armed and ready for for
anything and everything russia can throw
at you and i'm i'm i'm thinking of that
against
vladimir putin today meeting with his
top two generals you know they're seated
far apart at a table those generals
don't look happy vladimir putin doesn't
look exactly thrilled do you worry that
putin has become so unstable
uh that now he throws whatever caution
he's shown which is very little to the
wind and he goes crazy in a in an
all-out uh attack on civilians as well
and that this
this gets desperate for him and and
unhinged for him
well
couple of things first of all putin was
always crazy it's just that now world
sees him as crazy we knew that he was
crazy
for the last eight years when there was
a war on the east of ukraine
second is he going to regroup and he is
going to attack with all of his forces
yes definitely there has not been one
hour since the peace negotiations uh
when there was the most vicious and the
most aggressive attack on kiev uh in
terms of the firearms and in terms of
the air strikes then we experience in
five days
but
you know what we learned in eight years
that putin is lying all the time when he
says peace it means war when he says
okay i'm withdrawing my troops it means
i'm grouping my troops he said my army
is not there it means my army is here to
kill you and that's why we learn not to
trust him and that's why we are fighting
so hard because we know exactly what's
going to happen if he wins we know
exactly what the russian army going to
do to ourselves our children our cities
and that's why this is a desperate fight
this is a david versus goliath situation
and uh
this is with the high hopes we are going
to win this is where we need the help
and support from international community
because
we know what's going to happen if he
wins and we will not let him do that to
ourselves to our families our cities and
our country
gary thank you very very much be safe my
best to your family um
you and your fellow ukrainians have
inspired the world i think that's an
understatement stay safe stay well hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else